alright guys so we're going to start our
afternoon session two questions or not
hopefully not problems so I'm optimistic
that someone here will be able to
quickly solve these things I think
they're easy or maybe not I don't know
you guys can tell tell tell me at the
end of this if you look at my abstract I
was going to talk a little bit about
this different style of randomized
methods so these are these old Monte
Carlo methods that take a linear system
and turn it into some random walk
estimator and we had some recent work on
this but I decided to talk about
something different and so if you cared
about the first one and we're really
annoyed that I'm not doing it well
there's an archived paper that describes
everything I know about that one which
with all the bounds and yadda yadda
yadda so I'm gonna tell you about two
problems these are things where I don't
know the answer so the first one will
take about three slides to get to the
key question the second one that I'll
get a little bit more background for but
anyway again I hope these are easy so
again I don't have an answer to this I'm
not trying to be coy if it's really easy
please tell me that'd be great
so everyone I think has seen a slide
somewhat something like this before if
you take a random Erdos rainy graph and
you look at the eigenvalues of it you
get one of these semi circle laws and so
here what I'm doing is essentially I've
got three different graphs and I think
these are 200 note graphs and I'm
varying the average degree from 10 20 to
30 and I get I can values of the
normalized laplacian these things lie
between 0 & 2 and there's some nice semi
circle law that you can look up in the
textbook which will fit the eigenvalues
or the distribution of eigenvalues of
these things so I'm plotting empirical
distributions of eigenvalues like
Michael did yesterday for those neural
network weight things except these are
graphs now and again if you vary this
you can get sort of so as we go from an
average degree of 20 to an average to be
a 30 yes the distribution changes but it
changes in an expected way so this is
all well known nothing new there so
recently we've been doing a little bit
of work on what we at the time called
higher order data analysis but it's
really quite a simple idea so we're
given a graph here in some adjacency
matrix a and essentially what we're
gonna do is instead of working with the
adjacency Atrus matrix a we're gonna
work with this weighted matrix W is
equal to a squared Hadamard a what does
this matrix do well for each edge so
this is an element-wise product this is
going to count the number of triangles
that utilize that edge where does this
thing come up well this arises from work
when you try and generalize things like
graph cuts and all sorts of other things
to looking at them on tops of as
instances of motifs so you take a
regular graph here you enumerate all
triangles you sort of build a hyper
graph of this based on those triangles
and then you say let's look at you know
let's look for small conductance
partitions of this hyper graph it turns
out you can relate those back to this
matrix here it went the way you build
the hyper graph is a triangle and if you
want to read about that we have a whole
sequence of Pei Pei papert's about that
ok so then this begs the obvious
question what happens when you look at
this matrix with that Erdos Raney
construction look at the eigenvalues of
that note at the normalized laplacian of
this guy so what we're doing here is
we're gonna generate a random
erdos-renyi graph again we're looking at
the same thing wherever agrees 10 20 and
30 we're gonna compute this weighted
matrix W is equal to a squared Hadamard
a again this is a symmetric matrix so
this is essentially counting the number
of triangles incident of edge we're
gonna compute the eigenvalues of the
normalized laplacian of the largest
component of a it doesn't really matter
if you take the largest component of a
it's just if you don't do that you get a
little spike at zero here because these
things can be disconnected and then
we're gonna look at the distribution of
these things and so if you look at this
for the 10 10 20 and 30 you get things
that look very different these are
clearly not semi-circle laws if you
stare at them long enough and you look
at sort of distributions of random
matrices you would think
maybe this is a Marchenko pasture law
and so in in the blue or in the purple
curve here I've done my best to fit a
Marchenko pasture law to to this data
and as you can see so this is trying to
fit it to to the green curve which is
the densest one I thought that would be
the easiest one to fit it doesn't
actually fit to any of them as far as I
can tell but you know like it gets the
the sort of if I don't know if I want to
call this the head or the tail and it
gets this side right and it doesn't do
so well over on this side and I spent
some annoying amount of time playing
around trying to get combinations of
semi-circle and Marchenko pasture and
all sorts of other things to try and fit
these things better and I haven't had
any luck I've talked to some handful of
people and showed them these pictures
and everyone sort of scratches their
head say they have some interesting
distribution so the question is what is
this distribution can we characterize it
again I sort of hope this is an easy
question I think it's yes no I have not
asked you on it yet so is she here okay
well so now I have one more person to
check so in case you want to reproduce
this all the code is on this github gist
here so if anyone has a phone and what's
the like email her live or something
then maybe we could have an answer by
the end of the talk you know again it's
just a few lines of code to reproduce
these things you know it's possible some
convolution of things why is this matter
well essentially if you want to know why
this matters we actually get much better
results on partitioning stochastic block
models by doing this triangle
pre-processing first and so if you're
doing any type of linear algebra model
for partitioning stochastic block models
I've got a whole other talk I'm sort of
nice little things that you find when
you look at identifying partitions of
these stochastic block block block
models and these seem to be a lot more
robust than just doing things based on
the adjacency matrix so the idea would
be if we can characterize this might
that might actually help us understand
some slightly more robust things we can
do on those ones okay so that was the
easy one
the next one I is so this is another
problem or I don't know the answer and
this is going to evolve correlation
clustering of low rank matrices again if
you I can't stand suspense this one
essentially all what I'll talk about for
the next little bit except for the
question is on archive so there's a
paper we wrote about this that's on
archive that talks about it it doesn't
actually have posed this question the
question is just sort of left implicit
in the paper and so just to cut to the
chase one of the things we use here is a
heuristic randomized algorithm for
sampling vertices of zona topes we use
this to approximately solve binary
optimization problems and we get really
good results and the question is sort of
can you say anything more rigorous about
that and hey you get good results so we
find that empirically okay quick show of
hands who's heard of the correlation
clustering problem okay so some people
but most are a lot of people haven't so
I'm gonna give a quick introduction to
it there is extensive literature from a
whole host of communities on this one so
if you have a question it seems like I
didn't answer it there's probably a
reference somewhere out there who and
and or someone in the room who knows the
answer correlation clustering is this
nice formulation of the clustering
problem where rather than a given as
input data points what you're given is
input our relationships between data
points and so this takes the form of a
signed graph where a positive edge
indicates the two data points are
similar to each other and they should be
in the same cluster and a negative edge
which are drawn here with red dashed
lines indicate that two vertices want to
be in distinct clusters and so the nice
thing about this is there's no
specification this problem of the number
of clusters that you have if the input
graph or the input matrix we'll see that
this was really a matrix here in a
second is all positive then that means
that everyone wants to be in the same
cluster and so it's kind of like all
your vertices having a big group hugging
together and if everything is negative
that means that everyone's going to be
in their own individual fluster these
things can be weighted in general
weighted problems are
harder so you know hopefully they're not
we're gonna look at weighted cases and
there's two types of objectives that
people look at here the things that
people look at are essentially
minimizing the number of mistakes so
find me a clustering that makes as few
mistakes as possible the you know
essentially if I cluster these three
vertices here together as a negative
edge included and so I don't want to I
that's one mistake and then here is a
positive edge that's between clusters so
that's a different mistake and so I want
to minimize the number of these things
if there are weights I'm going to
minimize the sum of weights on those
edges as well another thing you could
look at is maximizing the weight of
agreement so you guys are minimize the
weight of mistakes or maximize the
weight of agreements from the
perspective of inter dropped ization
they're nice and the same from the
perspective of approximations they're
not at all the same so one is much
easier than the other but that's not
what I'm gonna consider here what we're
gonna look at is essentially taking this
and looking at these things as matrices
and then one of the great things about
having matrices is matrices are
sometimes low rank and so the question
is what happens with low rank
correlation clustering problems so you
might ask is this just an artificial
construction no there are actually
problems in the literature where they
legitimately have low rank correlation
clustering problems they're not all that
common but on the other hand we can do
some nice things with them so if your
matrix is rank one I think everyone in
the room would be very happy to be given
such a problem
this is a particularly nice correlation
clustering problem to have essentially
what we do is we have a positive
semi-definite matrix that's rank one if
we just sort that vector V we sort it
into two groups essentially vertices
that have negative entries and positive
entries so again what we're it's not
what what we're doing here is we're
taking this matrix of weights here and
assigning the weights corresponding to
the vertex to the vertex so now you're
the weight on your edge is the product
of your things
and so again essentially what you do is
you get groups based on the sign of this
thing so you just look at the signs of
these and you are happy this is an
optimal clustering all right some other
fun things essentially if you have a
single so so if you take correlation
clustering and take a sort of rank
perspective on this what you find is
first of all if you have a single
negative eigenvalue that turns your
problem into some sorry it basically
makes your problem and fee hard so even
if you have a rank one negative definite
matrix that's not something that we know
how to solve efficiently so we're gonna
just look at the case where and
everything is nice and positive definite
in which case it turns out that a rank
are positive definite matrix can be
solved in polynomial time in order n to
the R squared minus 1 so that's a lovely
runtime so I can solve that for a bot R
is equal to 2 for RS equals 3 that would
be an end of the eighth algorithm which
is not something we're going to be able
to do now essentially yes so the
algorithms are so so so the the the
simple one ok so essentially the the
right way to think about this is it
turns out that there's that there's an
equivalence between correlation
clustering the low rank sense on this
problem called vector partitioning and
vector partitioning can be solved via
essentially enumerated vertices of the
Zona taupe which is where we're sort of
going with this and so if you just
exhaustively explore all vertices of the
Zona taupe you must look at the optimum
clustering at some point and so you just
have to bound the number i mean it's
essentially just a bound on the number
of vertices of these things okay so
that's not something that's overly fun
it's based on some older work but in
some work we were doing about the same
time as we were working on this one we
actually had looked at a particular
randomized algorithm to sample vertices
of the Zona taupe if you haven't heard
what the zero fizzle I'll go over that
in a second
and so in Prak
just what we do is we find that this is
a highly effective procedure and to cut
to the chase the question is is there
anything we could say about this beyond
that hey this seems to work in practice
but we can't say anything more all right
so if you want to sort of see what the
vector partitioning problem is in this
case we've got a cluster C and what
we're trying to do is maximize the norm
squared of what are called some point so
at some point it's just the sum of all
the data points assigned to that cluster
and what we want to do is figure out a
cluster that maximizes this norm here
the sum of this norm it turns out it
takes a few lines of algebra but it's
not particularly complicated to show
that low rank correlation clustering and
the positive semi-definite case
correspond to this yes so when it's
ranked and and sorry so this is in
general and P hard but sorry when it's
positive semi-definite and rank n and
there's no negative eigenvalues that is
a good question I don't know off the top
of my head if that if that case is yeah
great great questions yeah so
okay so what is a zona taupe just
another quick show of hands who's heard
of as ona tote before
okay so fewer people in correlation
clustering I hadn't heard of these until
someone asked me what the heck happens
when you take a hypercube projected to a
low dimensional space take a picture of
it and try and find the convex hull so
it takes a while if someone describes
things that way to figure out that the
thing they're talking about the Zona
taupe there's some interesting story
about how we realized that that was
actually a zone hotel but essentially
what we we are given here is a D by n
matrix so think of D is smaller than n
and so n is going to be sort of some
ambient space and so G is going to take
stuff from a high dimensional space down
to a low dimensional space we're gonna
look at a hypercube here and we're going
to take all vertices of that project it
down to our low dimensional space and
then find the so a vertex of the zona
taupe is going to be essentially one of
the vertices of the convex hull of that
projection
okay so here's some cool stuff so at
that around that time what we were
looking at was the following randomized
algorithm to get a vertex of the zone Oh
dope you take a vector X that's just
essentially randomly distributed
according to a normal distribution you
multiply by G transpose you take the
sign of that and then you multiply the
sign of that output by G you do up there
there should be a star there which says
that nothing can be zero when you do
this but I'm interest of keeping the
slides nice I'm going to omit that step
and now what I'm plotting here is for a
two by three matrix G here what what
we're seeing is over a whole bunch of
samples how often you generate each
vertex and then here we have a 2 by 10
so essentially as we crank up the
dimension of that latent or that big
bigger space there first of all we get
more vertices so the circles here the
vertices and now the question that that
that we were trying to answer in some of
our work was what's the probability that
we get an individual vertex and so over
here you know it looks like as I'm sort
of throwing darts at this thing you know
at every yes so it turns out it says
yeah this will always give you a vertex
of the zona tope so it will always give
you one of them this there's a short
derivation as I said I just didn't put
put put put in here but if you look at
this this will always get you one it
will actually with nonzero probability
get you any so there's a probability
distribution
that'll give in a second that sort of
says what the probability you get any
particular one is but again for this one
as you throw throw throwing darts what
I'm showing here is essentially how many
accumulate in each of these vertices you
see you basically get them all with
roughly equal probability here for this
one if you look at this for a second you
say oh you know
there's a little bit of difference but
there's these two here that essentially
get almost like you're very unlikely to
get so if you're throwing darts it's
going to take a while to get those so
what what actually happens here again
this was another bit of fortuitous
timing here around the same time we were
working at this we happen to have a
conversation with some folks who had
worked on a very similar problem from a
different perspective but essentially we
were able to adapt those their results
and show that the probability that you
get a vertex of the Zona taupe is
proportional to the size of the normal
cone of that vertex and so what is the
normal cone if you've got a vertex you
sort of have this cone coming out at
right angles and so if you look at this
and you say hey what happens as this
thing gets flatter and flatter and
flatter well as it gets flatter and
flatter and flatter that's the size of
that normal cone shrinks and shrinks and
shrinks so here's another zona taupe
over here here are all of the sort of
vertices of the hypercube encircles and
then the x's are actually the vertices
of the zona taupe we've drawn the
regions here corresponding to basically
the probability that you'll generate
each of them and you can see that
there's these little slivers here where
you're highly unlikely to get those
vertices those ones correspond to
basically flat sides of the zona taupe
okay so this is zona taupe sampling
sorry was our question sorry the like it
seems like in the higher dimensions this
is giving the wrong idea right because
the corners get bigger and so forth so I
guess I have no intuition for higher
dimensions so yes I guess in higher
dimensions this is probably giving the
wrong idea
but yes
so essentially that this one so that
this one here is unlikely to be sampled
but there's I mean when you save
vertices nearby oh that is a great
question the short answer is I don't
know I'd need to think about a little
bit more so okay so back to correlation
clustering what the heck does
correlation clustering have to do with
zona copes well essentially there's this
thing called a signings oh no taupe
which allows you to associate vector or
sorry vertices of the zona taupe with
clustering so you so you specify the
number of clusters you want turns out
for low rank correlation clustering we
know exactly how many clusters to to
expect and then you generate a vertex of
this and then you sort of map those into
a zone oh taupe so the vectors G here
are given by your low rank vectors times
some information about R and s where R
and s represent clusters and so these
these things are sort of confusing but
essentially what this means is if you
get a vertex where this thing is
negative one it means that node I is not
in cluster R but could be in cluster s
and so once you get one of these
vertices you have to sort of like back
out what the actual clustering is by
figuring out oh this one's not in
cluster R could be an S well is it you
know just look at all all s and things
like that and again what what what this
corresponds to is basically you you you
do pairs of clusters because you're
getting quit or answers of the form not
in R but could be an S so there's some
pair pair wise thing go go go go wing on
there suffice it to say this isn't our
stuff here what we're doing is we're
looking at this random sampling
algorithm applied to of these things so
again rather than directly enumerate all
the vertices of these things which is
going to be expensive and hard to do in
practice what we're gonna do is just
compute some large number of vertices
via that sampling algorithm
and find the clustering of each and just
compute the objective function that we
get and so here's what happens as you
varied the number of iterations from 1
to 20,000 in this case this is a 3000
dimensional problem that's 5 dimensional
so this would be like a 3,000 to the
what is it like 29 or something like
that or something very sorry 20 for the
this is a synthetic problem here but you
can see that you know again we we sort
of get better and better and better but
just a little bit better on each
iteration so we start really good the
question is just really can we explain
this and so if you want another cute
example of this so here is an instance
of this where we took Google Trends data
on how often people are searching for
computer science conferences and
essentially D trended them and turn this
into a low rank correlation clustering
so now we're clustering conferences by
how people search for them on Google so
this is over a few years it turns out
that there are essentially two clusters
that come out of this their conferences
who search volume is decreasing and
conferences who search volume is
increasing I expect most people are
publishing in these places and not in
these ones but we'd have to double check
that so curiously for this one it's
actually pretty easy to solve so using
our stuff we can actually get an optimal
objective value in about seven seconds I
believe so like the zona tope will find
the correct answer pretty quickly
there's another common algorithm for
correlation clustering called pivot that
one also finds it's even faster this
one's based on an LP that's extremely
expensive to solve it also finds the
optimal solution but it takes a little
bit less than an hour
you can also solve the integer LP for
this one as well which is how we know
that these things are optimal so back to
the question I guess for the purpose of
these clusterings are there better ways
of sampling the vertices of the zona
tope then just this simple idea that
we've been looking at but more
importantly is there anything like an
approximation bound we can give for
these stuff style of algorithms
based on some type of objective and so
if you want another reason why you might
care about this there's all sorts of
nice relationships between solving low
rank binary QPS and zonah Topa
numeration so it'd be nice to sort of
see what those are like so again just in
summary here the two questions so for
the problem of arrow rainy graphs or
those triangle Erdos rainy graphs what
the heck is this distribution so
hopefully I'll have an email off that
might answer this one by the end of this
and then for this zona taupe sampling
algorithm what the can we say anything
beyond yes we get probabilities of those
oh no - or sorry we get vertices of
those oh no topes basically proportional
to their normal counts thanks yes so we
know the number of clusters there's a I
think it's D plus one clusters so this
this comes out of this vector
partitioning problem so it's easiest to
see this in three dimensions actually
here I can show it back here
so essentially when you look at this
like a vector partitioning problem it
turns out that in order to be optimal
the some points have to be at larger
than 90 degrees from each other each
other so in two dimensions the number of
vectors you can have at more than 90
degrees from each other is exactly three
so for a rank two problem you get three
clusters and it turns out is if you
generalize this you get D plus one
clusters so that that that's the upper
bound
you could have fewer than that but in
general you're like unless there's some
further low dimensional structure or
some sort of singular structure and
these you're not go go I mean you'll
you'll use all all of the clusters if
your algorithm does that give you
something immediately for a correlation
clustering or for another problem where
it's not really clear it's like there's
two questions so there's two questions
there I mean it's really like is there
anything so so at the moment I don't
like we don't essentially have a good
map between anything about the objective
function and vertices of these things
and so I don't even know if uniform
sampling would help there are other
cases where that might actually help but
for this particular one I don't think it
goes like that the short answer I don't
know it's not a vertex then it's you
know that it's not correct that sort of
suggests that if it's almost not a
vertex then it's probably not a very
good clustering right so so it yeah
yes I agree that sounds reasonable we
you know again we'll need to do some
more thinking about this
yeah so if you do that go back to your
first part yes
so you we've looked at I don't think I
ever drew the eigenvalue plots for fork
leaks the the problem is that the with
Erdos rainy graphs the probability that
you get larger and larger cleek sort of
decays quite rapidly and so when we do
social networks yes we do periodically
look at fourth leaks and five weeks and
that's actually pretty interesting
but for Erdos rainy I don't know that
that's gonna be all that in interesting
just because at some point you're just
yeah absolutely so essentially what
we're doing here is I'm varying average
degree here instead of P just cuz I I
can never reason about P and I can
always reason about average degree so
essentially the probability P here is
going to give I mean these are three
different choices of P that are you know
this one's quite more compact than this
one is this one actually is pretty
interesting
okay
[Applause]